this could be a clever play for Elon
where they finally get Twitter onto a
decentralized system where no one can be
banned ever again he says we're not even
it's not even up to us yeah so if they
go I I don't know if you're saying
Noster Noster yeah but or or what's the
other one uh um the ferse MH the FSE so
these are like protocols where anyone
can plug into any other one basically
like the internet if Elon Musk says
Twitter is now going to be open source
and Federated that means you could be
signed up for gab and tell someone oh if
you're follow me you know Ryan gab.com
and then if someone's on X they can type
that in and follow you wherever they are
so this would mean that X Twitter
whatever could no longer ban anybody
wouldn't that be like destroying his
investment though like the if the
company is going to go under because the
advertiser is canceled yeah and then
he's just like well the company's dead
unless we open source and Federate also
if you open source you could put stuff
in where if if there is advertisement
for every million dollars Disney pulls
another censorship person gets fired